el deseo de ganar una y otra vez es la
marca que ha convertido a serena
williams en una leyenda del tenis
pero esta vez la campeona perdió ante la
australiana tomljanovic en la tercera
ronda del usopen fue probablemente el
último partido de su larga carrera tras
un anuncio de retiro el mes pasado
aunque todavía dejan duda cuándo será su
salida de las canchas al insinuar que
podría jugar el slam australiano en
enero
no lo sé no estoy pensando en eso sin
embargo siempre me encantó australia
pero si sabes que he recorrido un largo
camino desde el año pasado en wimbledon
solo que no estoy segura de si ese fue
mi último momento o no hacer que sea un
momento diferente creo que es mucho
mejor
en el de forma en que es much perder
en tu caso su paso por el open fue un
momento único para los aficionados
es la más grande de todas no creo que
nadie pueda igualar la lo que ha
conseguido no se puede comparar en el
deporte para mujeres su para hombres
estamos muy orgullosos de esa barba
ha tomado su decisión está en la cima de
su carrera a los 40 años es una de las
mejores atletas del mundo estamos muy
orgullosos de ella y no importa que haya
perdido
desde su derrota los homenajes no paran
de llegar de deportistas como tiger
woods
serena williams eres literalmente la
mejor dentro y fuera de la cancha
gracias por inspirarnos a todos a
perseguir nuestros sueños te amo
hermanita o personalidades de la
televisión estadounidense
25 años campeona heroína eres una
leyenda para siempre con 23 títulos de
grand slam y 6 años en el número 1
serena williams habrá forjado uno de los
mejores palmarés del deporte mundial
[Aplausos]